- As a consultant you spend a lot
of time in interviews with clients.
So, you sit together
with clients in meets,
ask them questions, and pretty much want
to extract information from them.
The same is, of course, true
for corporate professionals.
You will often sit
together with colleagues,
ask them questions potentially
from other departments,
try to learn from their role, and try
to get information that
is relevant to your job.
This is exactly the topic of today.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm a former McKinsey
consultant and project lead.
And in this video I'm going
to share my top five tips
of how to conduct great
and professional interviews
based on my own experience in consulting.
So, without further ado let's get
started with the five tips.
And tip number one is
to strategically think
about who is scheduling the meeting?
As a young consultant
maybe you're a bit naive,
as for sure I was, so
you might just think,
oh, okay, I want to have
an interview with this guy.
Let me just hit him up
and send him an invite.
And while this might work
perfectly fine in many cases,
what might happen to you
is that you're facing
some kind of political situation,
where then the client if
he just sees an invite
from a junior consultant maybe tells you,
ah, no, you know, this week
my schedule is so busy.
Maybe next week we can find a spot,
maybe 30 minutes end of next week.
But this can often be
quite difficult for you.
Because one week can be a
very long amount of time
in the context of a project,
where maybe the whole project
only goes six, seven, eight weeks.
So, my advance again
would be to think about
who sends the invite, who
is asking for the meeting.
Does it really need to be you?
Or is there maybe a
way that the supervisor
of the person you want to talk to asks
for the meeting, invites the person?
Because, of course, this often puts
the meeting much higher on the agenda.
The importance is of
much more significance
if this is the way the
meeting is scheduled
than if you are the one asking for it.
Tip number two, before you walk into
such a meeting or such
an interview situation
ask yourself, what would success mean?
So, after the meeting,
what would you know now?
What you have received from the client
for the meeting to be a success for you?
The worst thing that can
happen in these situations
is that you walk into
a meeting unprepared,
maybe just have a broad topic
in your mind that you want to talk about.
But the meeting pretty much
lacks a lot of structure.
And afterwards all types of questions come
to your mind that you
would have liked to ask,
but someone forgot to ask in the moment.
In addition to that, of
course, coming unprepared
to such a meeting can
also seem unprofessional.
And in a political situation
where you're maybe facing
a hostile client he might
also call you out for that.
And then maybe afterwards he walks across
the organization and
talks to his colleagues,
maybe his teammate, or
maybe even a board member
that the consultants from
this and this consulting firm
are unprofessional, were unprepared
when conducting the interview with them.
Of course, this is an impression
that you will always want to avoid.
This will make you look
bad as an associate,
but will also make your whole
consulting firm look bad.
So make sure that you're well-prepared,
write down the questions
that you want to ask.
Think about a structure for the interview
that you want to conduct.
And if you want to learn more
about this I recently made,
also, a video about
note-taking, how to write down
these insights that you
get from the interview.
If you want to learn more
about it check out the video.
I will link it somewhere above here.
Tip number three is to be
empathetic with your client
and focus on listening and not talking.
Many young consultants seem to tend
towards talk a lot in these meetings.
You want to prove that you
know what you're talking about.
You want to prove that you're competent.
So when you observe rather
unexperienced people
often you see that they try to talk a lot.
They try to get a lot of
airtime in these settings.
What is much better, though,
and one thing that is emphasized in many,
many onboarding training programs
of these consulting firms is to focus
on letting the client speak,
and see yourself rather
in a listening role.
In the end you want
information from the client.
This is what in most cases will
really help you and the project.
As a rule of thumb for
these interviews try
to restrict your speaking share to 20%.
So you talk 20%, the client talks 80%.
Focus on listening.
But when you listen don't just sit there
and try to put on a poker face.
But try to engage in active listening.
So whenever the client says something try
to occasionally say,
okay, yes, understood,
understood, thank you,
mm-hmm, mm-hmm, okay.
Give them the impression that
you are actively listening,
that you're actively
processing what he is saying.
This would often
encourage them to give you
even more information, to talk more.
And of course, these are the ingredients
of a successful interview.
And, of course, highly related to that
is the importance of being empathetic.
Try to really reach your client.
If he is telling you something,
if he is saying something to
you, what are his feelings?
Is he comfortable, is he
uncomfortable with the situation?
Is he starting to become defensive?
Is this is a topic he's
super enthusiastic about?
He might even want to share
even more with you on.
Reading the room in this
way is really crucial
to get a feeling for also
all the political situations,
which are always so important
in corporate contexts.
There's pretty much no
thing that is as important
as empathy when interacting with clients.
This is also something you can learn.
It's a skill that you can develop.
To focus on that start to become sensitive
for these kinds of topics.
Now, tip number four,
this is a little tactic
that you can do in the
middle of an interview.
And this is what I learned from a project
lead I worked together with.
We were both sitting in the
interview with a client.
We were asking the client
a couple of things.
And he then said something,
gave us a short and brief answer.
But it was clear that we
needed much more from him.
And he apparently wasn't really willing
to just give it all out,
just give it all away.
So, what I observed my project lead doing
is that after we got a
little bit of information
he didn't just ask one
question after the other
trying to ask for it, trying to fish
for the other things
that he wanted to hear.
But he was just pretty much looking
at the client and saying nothing.
And he was doing that
for quite a long time,
up to the moment when it
really felt uncomfortable.
And this is really a
tactic that you can employ
for your conversations as well.
People often feel very
uncomfortable in moments of silence.
People will have the urge to break
the silence, to say something,
to provide you with
additional information.
Of course, it's important to be
a bit careful with this, don't overdo it.
But try this out occasionally.
And in the right moments this
can be a little technique
that really makes the difference
and can suddenly open up
a client who wasn't
really willing and open
to share information with
you in the beginning.
So, make use of this power of silence.
And, also, leave me a
comment if you've done
something similar in the past.
Let me know how this worked out.
My fifth tip is to
always write a follow-up,
always write meeting minutes
after these conversations.
Often, in these meetings
in the end you agree
on a couple of things, maybe
to-dos that you are doing,
or the client is doing, or
some other types of next steps.
But, then, what I have
really frequently seeing
is that then maybe if you do not put
this in writing, then a week passes.
Maybe a week later nothing has happened.
And then if you talk to
the client and confront him
on something that he wanted to do,
then you will often see
that he did not do that.
He might also frame that
as a misunderstanding,
that maybe it wasn't really clear to him
that this is really something
that you expected him to do.
So just make it a habit
of yours that pretty much
always after these meetings,
after these interviews,
you just write a very short email.
Just make it bullet point format.
Just write down what you agreed on,
what you discussed, what the results were.
And, especially, also specific to-dos
if either you or the
client agree to something.
You will quickly see that
this is a habit that makes
your whole client relationship
much more reliable.
This is also a technique that you can use
to build trust with your client.
There is a very helpful framework
that is often taught
in executive education
and also consulting onboarding programs.
And this is called the trust formula.
And I don't want to go
into too much detail now.
Because it will be a
topic for a future video.
But pretty much what it comes
down to is that creating
these moments where
you agree on something,
and the client agrees on something,
and then both of you deliver
against these promises,
these often create
opportunities to create trust.
This is how trust is formed and created.
This is how you can build, and sustain,
and deepen your client relationship.
I hope you found these
tips helpful and applicable
to your work reality as well, independent
whether you work in consulting,
industry, or banking.
If you have any more questions you'd like
to ask me feel free to leave me
a comment below in the comments section.
I will do my very best to
answer every single comment.
And, of course, on top of
that, if you leave a comment
you'll also help me
with the YouTube system,
so every comment is much appreciated.
In addition, if you took any value out
of this video at all please hit
the like button for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe to my channel
to stay up-to-date on all my content.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
If you want to see even more from me,
also following me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning.
I also have an email
newsletter you can find
the sign up link in the video description.
And I'm also happy to connect and stay
in touch with you in LinkedIn.
So, feel free to hit me up
on LinkedIn and get in touch.
I now want to say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really helping me
significantly with the channel.
If you are considering to become a member
as well hit the join button
next to the subscribe button
to learn about what it would
mean to become a member
and learn about all the
perks that I've got for you.
If you watched until the very end
thank you so much, I very appreciate it.
So, see you again next
Saturday with the new video.
And until then good weekend to you guys.